Since we've been coding for
a while now, I wanted to pause to
check back in with Roman Nurik at our
Design Center in New York City
to talk a bit more about design.
[SOUND] Roman, once again,
thanks for your time.
Do you think that every mobile app
developer should strive to become
a designer?
>> Well, I don't think it's
necessarily important for
every developer to become a designer,
and stop doing their engineering work.
I do think, though,
that every developer,
every front end developer,
should have some sense of design.
And I also think that, really,
as a mobile developer,
you're already doing design work, right?
Whether you like it or
not, you are creating,
you're crafting the experience for
the end-user.
And so what I think is important is
just knowing that this is something that
you're participating in.
This is not something that
is being handed to you, and
you're just executing on.
Knowing that this is something you're
participating in, I think it's super
important for developers to
really kind of study up on it.
To get as good as possible at
observing the differences,
observing the little details and really
kind of caring about every little,
I hate saying every little pixel, but
every little decision here and there.
And so I think rather than saying every
developer should become a designer,
I think every developer should
really understand design.
Always understanding also that you're
going to be working in a team, and
kind of understanding what your
designers are good at and so forth.
So, yes.
[LAUGH]
In short.
>> For me, that's super interesting.
And you can definitely see how we're
using material in our cross platform
experiences here at Google.
While being true, in many ways,
to the unique element of each platform.
Design has become so much more important
in building applications of all sorts.
And I think it's really important for
every engineer to at least be familiar
with the palliative options available
to them and to their designers.
To that end, Roman Nurik,
Nick Butcher, and James Williams,
are developing a terrific
course in material design,
that any front end engineer
should experience.